some artists spend their entire lives
creating their work
others become artists they say by
accident that's exactly what happened to
a man in england
who sold dozens of pet portraits he said
at first he was only pretending to be an
artist
then it turned into a way to lift
people's spirits and help the community
at the same time
roxanna suberi has the story
phil heckel says he was never much of an
artist
but a few weeks ago he was trying to get
his son sam to make a few thank you
cards
and just to try to get him interested i
said hey i'm going to draw a picture of
nyla
our dog he drew this one and this one
then he posted them on facebook writing
for sale
beautiful hand-drawn pictures of your
favorite family pets
for roughly four hundred dollars each
it was a joke but serious requests began
pouring in thousands of them so
he began transforming pictures of pets
into cartoons of cross-eyed dogs
long-legged cats and more i can't get my
head around the fact that
so many people seem to like what i'm
doing it is just
bonkers he signs his sketches with his
pseudonym
hercule van wolfe winkle and leaves
funny fake
customer reviews like did you draw this
in the dark with your eyes closed
it was all this tongue and cheek thing
of i'd set up this business and have
become a portrait
artist but when people offered to pay
for their pet portraits
he asked them to donate instead to a
local homeless charity
so far he's raised more than 45 thousand
dollars
why do you think people like your
drawing so much i don't know
um i mean i think the honest answer is
they make people smile
and so there's not a lot to smile about
at the moment
one man even turned hercules drawing
into a tattoo
there's no going back from that and it
was a terrible picture as well but i
guess it was his dog
hercule may not be the best artist in
the world but he might be one of the
fastest
we watched him sketch this cute puppy
named scott
and this police dog from henderson texas
how long do you think you're going to
keep going
right now for i can't see it stopping um
so forever well i don't know about
forever that's a long time
but this doodling dad says if he can
keep lifting spirits and raising money
for a good cause
he won't put down his pencils anytime
soon
for cbs this morning roxanna seberry
worthing england
roxanna that's will's favorite son
will's dog scott
what it's a nice surprise that's there
he is
he's oh i love that look that's what you
call puppy dog
his drawings have real personality
that's what that's what they really have
a personality which is
which is the hardest thing to achieve
you could make a better
likeness but to put the personality in
is what's really special but what he
said too that i think really strikes the
court is that it makes you smile yes
the one with the dog with the tongue
hanging out the one with the bad hairs i
like the cross-eyed dog i like that
outside dog always works
very nice yeah it's very nicely done you
know i also i also sketched a few things
to try to get my older son interested in
drawing and it didn't turn out the same
way
yeah i didn't get the 400 uh per picture
uh
payment but that's wonderful very nice